what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 6 of the Python 3 basics series in
this part what we're going to be talking
about is functions so we can use
functions to help us kind of consolidate
code into one area that we might intend
to use in many areas or many other even
different Python scripts even later we
could like import it and when you when
you see something like what we have here
where you know we want it you know
initially define the game map then we
want to come down here and we want to
display the game map then we want to
come here after the user has made their
play let's say we want to display the
game map again because it's changed and
we want to show what has the change been
well the problem is you know basically
these this like block of code here and
here is identical so aside from just
like you know taking up space and in
general just being somewhat problematic
what happens if at some point you want
to make thank thank you for your support
with Safari oh that's funny that's the
first time that's ever happened while I
was recording that I guess I'll leave
that in if you want to support the
content you can click that blue j--
blue join button there and maybe just
maybe get one of the best shoutouts ever
my record that's funny thanks again was
for you okay where was I anyway we've
got repetition of code here and what if
like for example that one of the reasons
aside from taking up space it still
can't get over that one other besides
from taking up space
the problem is later what if rather than
ABC you want to call this zero one two
right then if you wanted to make that
change you're gonna have to go from here
and like start copying and pasting or
maybe you'll get fancy and use a Find
and Replace but what if it's like multi
lines and then what if
there's like slight variable changes
guess what you're gonna make a mistake
and you're gonna ruin something so
instead what you wanted to use and begin
to use is functions so anytime you've
got repetition in your code even if it's
not identical like sometimes that
repetition might have slight differences
chances are you should be using a
function or maybe even a full loop or
something like that but in this case we
should definitely be using a function
because we just want to like call this
block of code to run pretty much every
time a player has made a move so for
example what if we just let's just
define a function so to define a
function you'll just use the EF space
and then the function name and up to
this point I really haven't talked at
all about styling and like pep eight
which is the Pythons version of all the
styling rules but in general variables
should all be kind of like lowercased
you you don't want to like camel case or
title case variables like you might in
other languages functions same thing it
should all be lower cased words would be
separated by underscore so for the most
part I do my best to keep this tutorial
pep eight so for example so we could
call this game board right that would be
that's clearly so like if someone was to
import your script and import game board
from your script immediately people know
okay that's a function as opposed to
later down the line maybe you've got a
class something that makes object you
wouldn't call it this way you would call
it in title casing which is what we use
for classes and again if someone was to
import that and all they saw was the
name they would know immediately that's
a class so that's that's why we do
styling like this and we try to have
everybody do the same styling so it's
easy it's even easier to read people's
code anyways this is a function after
you to find your font you know you're
given your function name you've got
parentheses inside the parentheses go
any parameters that you want to use in
your function for now we're not going to
use any just so we can understand what a
functions doing at first and then we can
talk about parameters when you're done :
boom new line it stabbed over since
Python doesn't use brackets it uses
whitespace to denote you know code
blocks so now basically we want this
function to do this so I'm gonna cut I'm
gonna come over here paste and then you
can highlight these and then at least in
sublime you can hold ctrl and then
basically the closing square bracket to
tab it over and that will give you
you've got a function all this function
does is just runs this block of code so
it just prints it doesn't doesn't do or
modify anything it just prints things
out so what we can do now is call this
function to run so game underscore board
and a super common mistake that people
make when they want to run a function is
this just they say game board well game
board just points to the function it
doesn't ask the function to run it just
points to it so so I'll try to show that
here in a second but to run it you want
to do game board and parenthesis okay so
that tells python run this function not
just hey this is the function because
you could assign the function to a
variable which I'll show in a moment so
game board that'll print it out and then
let's say we make a move now copy and
then let's get rid of this code here
paste game board I set up with beep f8
and I've got all this crazy space that's
the only Pepe time gonna violate by the
way hopefully anyways I also think there
should be two two lines I think before
functions some of the Pepe it is kind of
like you're not supposed to have more
than 78 characters a line forget about
that rule I think that's a silly rule
but I think to two separate function
blocks I think it's two lines unless
it's another function like it's another
function it's all just like one extra
line anyways in a little bit maybe one
of these videos I'm going to show you
guys how to install a linter into
sublime because that helps answer all
your questions
anyways run it okay so we can see that
here's the first game map here we made
our move now here's the second game map
he
and you can see that we okay we had
definitely played there now the next
thing I want to show is what I was
talking about so what if what if you
accidentally forgot the parenthesis
what's gonna happen nothing really
happens the game board is modified so
later if you called game board like this
everything's going to continue to work
it's just because this function doesn't
do anything but later you might want
that function actually you know do
something and you're gonna be like why
isn't it doing anything it's because you
forgot your parentheses so later what
I'll show you is like so for example
when you do just that it just points to
the function you can get kind of fancy
with that you could say x equals game
board and then you make your game
modification you actually could call X
now you you've basically X is equal to
that game board function now you run X
and you could run this and you see here
how it still acts like game board so
anyway
pretty nifty there but that's why you
can do that but just don't forget when
you want to run the game board function
you have to use the parentheses so the
next thing I want to talk about is
parameters so at some point you've got
your game board and you're going to want
to pass like so for example probably
every time we call the game board we
actually want to just play a move so at
the same time because that's gonna be a
repetitive repeated or repetitive I
couldn't decide in my brain before I
said it
anyway that's gonna be a repetitive code
where you know you take input from the
user you make the move like this we're
gonna be doing stuff like this all the
time so what we probably want to do is
pass some way both the input from the
user the setting of the user in the
actual you know on the actual game board
and all that like where they wanted to
play all that stuff we really want to
continue building that in our function
but to do that we need parameters so
that's what we're gonna do in the next
video if you've got questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below come hang out with us in the
discord
if you feel so inclined click that
beautiful blue button right there and
this red button here if you haven't
otherwise I will see you guys in the
next video